Đúng tắm dơ sáng ngày mệt thằng một.
Ngà hơi đại biểu tồn khu đường thứ mề bốn của đàn khai mặt trọng thế tại Trung tâm vội ý Quốc gia hà nội.
Với sự thăm dưới của một ý nâm trăm tắm mệt sáo đại biểu đại viện cho hơn năm phải sáo chiệu đàn viên.
Sau lễ trọng cơ, đoàn Trung tịch gồm mệt sáo đồng chiếc.
Bản thức kiếc gồm năm đồng chiế lên làm việc.
Bản Trung tịch gồm mệt sáo đồng chiếc viên bộ chiến chiếc.
Đồng chiế tốt lắm, tổng mệt thứ bán chất hành Trung đàn cộng sản Việt Nam,
chủ tịch bán chủ tịch.
Đồng chiế luôn cơm, chủ tịch nước,
đồng chiế phạm miếc chính, bí thư đảo ở chính vụ,
tụ tưởng chính vụ, đồng chiếc trần thánh bánh,
bí thư đảo ở ý Quốc hội, chủ tịch gồm hội,
đồng chiếc trần cầm tố,
thường trường bán bí thư,
bí thư đảo ở ý các thật quan đàn Trung gần.
Đồng chiế lên mình hơn,
bí thư Trung đàn,
chở bán tổ chức Trung gần,
đồng chiế phán định trạc,
bí thư Trung đàn,
chở bán ở chính Trung gần,
đồng chiếng bên dân tháng,
giám đông ở Việt chính chỉ cũng ra hội chính mình,
chủ tịch ở đồng liên chuẩn gần,
đồng chiếc buổi tìm mình hoài,
bí thư Trung đàn,
bí thư đảo ở ý mặt trận tổ khó,
các bạn thấy Trung gần,
chủ tịch bán Trung gần mặt trận tổ khó về nằm.
Đồng chiếng ngưỡng hoặc mình,
phó bí thư tưởng trận đồng ý chính vụ,
hó tưởng tưởng trận chính vụ,
đồng chiếc độ bán chến,
phó bí thư tưởng trận đồng ý Quốc hội,
phó trận tịch tưởng trận khó hội,
đại tưởng phán ngăn rằng,
phó bí thư của người Trung gần,
bổ trận bộ Quốc phòng,
đại tưởng lương tâm quan,
bí thư đảng ý của quan Trung gần,
bổ trận bộ công an,
đồng chiếng bên văn nên,
thương trực tều bán bán kiện đại của bị bốn của đàn,
đại tưởng bên trong nghĩa,
bí thư Trung gần đàn,
bí viên bán tưởng vụ của người Trung gần,
chủ giấm tổng cuộc chính chỉ của đội nhân dân Việt Nam,
đồng chiếng vận suyên gần,
bí thư thành người hà nội,
thay mặt loàn chủ tịch đại hội,
đồng chiế trận cầm tố,
bí viên bổ chính chỉ,
thường trực bán bí thư,
giới thiệu đại biểu và khách mời của đại hội,
thay mặt loàn chủ tịch,
đồng chiếc phạm miếng chính,
bí viên bổ chính chỉ,
hủ tưởng chiếc phủ đều hà yên trên thay mặt,
thay mặt loàn chủ tịch,
đồng chiế lương cường,
bí viên bổ chính chỉ,
chủ tịch nước,
chính bây dễn bán khai mặt đại hội,
đồng chiế tổ nghĩ tư tố lân,
chính bây báo cáo của bán chấp hành chuẩn đảng khoảng miế bà,
về các văn kệnh chính đại hội mới bốn của đàn,
kể thống dự thảo các văn kệnh chính đại hội gồm,
dự thảo báo cáo chính chỉ của bán chấp hành chuẩn đảng khoảng miế bà,
dự thảo báo cáo tổng kết một số vấn đề lý luận và thực hiện về công cuộc đối mới theo định giường sau,
chúng nghĩa trong 4,5,5,5,5,
dự thảo báo cáo tổng kết 15 năm thì hành điều lệ đang,
dây đoạn hành hủng trong 15 năm và đe sốt định giống dựng sự đổi bố xung điều lệ đang,
trong đó, dự thảo báo cáo chính chỉ,
tích hợp đồng cuộc bà báo cáo,
báo cáo chính chỉ báo cáo pin tây xa hội
và báo cáo tổng kết công tác xe dự đàn,
tạo thành một chính thế thống nhất,
tăng dịnh, vóa trộng tâm, trong biệm,
ngán ngọt, dễ hiểu, dễ nhớ, dễ chình khai,
chương trình hành động thực hiện,
khi cưới đại hội bị bố nha đồ phá,
sau khi các đại hội trước đây chỉ gió chủ thể lộ trình một lực,
đích đến để chình khai thực hiện,
khi cưới đại hội bị bốn,
được sự hội hội của hội như Trung hương mấy lắm,
khoảng 18, bộ chính chỉ để xuất đại hội cho chủ trường
tổng kết 15 năm, dựa sự lãnh đạo của đàn cũng sản Việt Nam,
tựa 1 yên chính trong 18 mươi đến hành hủng trong 18 mươi,
với khách nạn Việt Nam,
đình hưởng phát triển đến nước của trong năm tiếp theo,
từ hành hủng trong 18 mươi đến hành hình một trong 18 mươi,
tổng kết 14 năm từ khiến kương lĩnh sây dựng đất nước trong thời ký quá đồ
lên truyền hợp, trong quá trình hành thiện văn kiện,
bán cho hành truyền đảng 4 chính trị,
bán bị thư, tắc biệt có trọng việc phát triển kể tập thể,
mở giống dân chủ, lãnh hài sợ sắc thiện nói của đàn viên của nhân dân,
bộ đổi mũ chính thức nhà khoa học,
ra nhân, bán nghệ sĩ, gắn bộ,
chính sĩ lực lượng vũ tràng, đồng báo ta ở trong và ngoài nước,
dự thảo các văn kiện đã được thảo lượng dộ giả trong tàn đảng,
công bố công khai trên các phương tiện thúc tìm đại trống,
lấy kiến các đại biểu cuối hội mà chận thuốc quốc các tổ chức chính trị xa hội,
các tổ lấp nhân dân bằng nếu hình thức không phủ,
chỉ trong một tháng đá ngân 5 chiệu lợp cám bộ đàn viên nhân dân,
đong có vơ mềm bộ những chiệu lợp ý kiến của nhân dân,
hửa vê các tổ bán văn kiện được chấp lọc tiếp thù nghiêm tốt,
có phần làm nếu mở báo cáo chính trị là sự kết tình chỉ tòi,
sự mạnh của nhân dân, là sự hoặc vệnh giữa í đàng và lòng dân,
thức sự là ngọt bố sông đường là cầm năng đồng cho phần đảng,
phần dân, phần cuôn tàn.
Bán thức kí đại hội báo cáo dành sẽ thư định mừng của các đảng,
tổ chức quốc tế người tới chúc mừng đại hội lên thứ 14 của đảng.
Theo đó tính đến ngày 15 chiến tháng 1 năm nay,
những khuộc trong hệ sấu,
tài hội đã nhận được năm 15 mi chiến thư,
định mừng từ một trong lý chiến chính đảng,
sấu tổ chức quốc tế và khu vực,
mấy sấu cá nhân,
một trong 2,5 tuổi trức nhân dân và 8,5 tuổi năng ở nước ngoài.
Đây là ngồn của vũ đồng viên to lớn,
đối với công cuộc tối mới của nhân dân Việt Nam.
Gió đàn cụm sản Việt Nam khởi sướng và lãnh đạo,
cũng là biểu dẫn xin đồng của quan hệ hiệu nghị hợp tăng ngày càng xúc sắp,
giữa đảng tám với các chính đảng,
tổ chức và bạn mẹ cũng tế.
Cũng như tình cảm ngày càng gắn mó của kêu báo đối với kêu hồn đất nước.
Đại hội mẹ tò chân trọng và cảm ơn nông nhật,
bởi sử ủng hộ và những tình cảm quy báo mặt các đảng
tổ chức kêu báo và bạn mẹ cũng tế đã dành cho lại hội bốn.
Giành cho đảng nhắn nước và nhân dân Việt Nam.
Bà nhân dân sẽ tiếp tục cập cho tục tình đại hội.
Đúng tình hình.
Cái quyết tâm đổi mới tìm gì.